this month the Playstation Plus game
catalog is gaining some big additions
members at the extra and premium tiers
can look forward to playing the Elder
Scrolls 5 Skyrim special edition Tom
Clancy's Rainbow Six Siege Ghost Recon
breakpoint and the division two but
that's not all because soaring their way
into the game catalog is Sora and gang
with Kingdom Hearts HD 1.5 plus 2.5
remix 2.8 Final Chapter prologue Kingdom
Hearts 3 and Melody of memory will this
finally be my opportunity to become a
Kingdom Hearts Die Hard nope God of War
Ragnarok is out I'm busy and you might
be as well because earlier this month
PlayStation added three free games to
the essential PlayStation Plus tier neo2
a Yokai slashing action game from Team
ninja that combines the pinpoint
swordplay of Ninja Gaiden with the
mechanics of Dark Souls the Lego Harry
Potter collection a game that combines
years one through four and years 5
through 7 into one game and the
physics-based puzzle game Heavenly
Bodies but I won't be able to beat all
the those games either because Modern
Warfare 2's first season is about to
take up all my other free time a week
from today on November 16th Modern
Warfare 2 will get its first major
update with the launch of season 1 and
Warzone 2.0 will be Unleashed on the
masses in a blog post Activision ran
through the specifics of what's new in
season one and it's a lot of information
Modern Warfare 2 is adding fan favorite
maps in season 1 and those include shoot
house and shipment and according to
Activision both maps are reimagined for
Modern Warfare 2. season 1 also adds a
new battle pass players can now choose
from different sectors of the battle
pass so they can choose to focus on
progression towards specific items in
whatever order they want additionally
season 1 adds a new spec ops mission and
the game's first raid Activision said
the raid will be narrative focused as it
continues the Modern Warfare 2 story in
some capacity finally season one for
Modern Warfare 2 adds a new seasonal
Prestige system featuring more
challenges and rewards as well as CDL
Mosh Pit which is a more competitive
multiplayer mode it's the precursors of
ranked play which is coming in 2023 the
new Warzone 2.0 map is called almazra
and it will feature 18 points of
interest for players to explore for Zone
2.0 also includes a new experience
called DMZ this is an open world
narrative focused extraction mode where
players fight alone or together with the
aim of getting to the chopper to escape
additionally Warzone 2.0 includes an
updated Gulag it will now be a 2v2 setup
featuring random paired teams who work
together to take down another team to
earn redeployment additionally the new
Gulag has an enemy called a Jailer who
shows up in the middle of the fight to
speed up combat finally Warzone 2.0 is
adding third person playlist which marks
a first for the Battle Royale series
these playlists won't be available at
launch on November 16th but are coming
sometime later during season one let me
know in the comments if you plan on
playing Warzone 2.0 know exclusively
third person or first person